الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع تجري حاليا في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم او كما يطلق عليها
العاصمه المثلثه الانقسامها الى ثلاث مدن
الخرطوم ام درمان والخرطوم بحري هذه المدن
تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى بعدد سكان يتراوح ما
بين ثمانيه الى عشره ملايين نسمه منهم
مقيمون ومتنقلون اليها يوميا الاشتباكات
الجاريه حاليا متداخله في المدن الثلاث
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وفي حال
اتساع رقعه القتال سيكون امام قاطني
الخرطوم طريق الجنوب للنزوح على النيلين
الابيض والازرق وفيما يتعلق بسكان الخرطوم
بحري امامهم التحرك شمالا او شرقا اما
سكان ام درمان فستكون المدن الواقعه غرب
وشمال وجنوب ام درمان ملادهم للنزوح